[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de cultura de
france 24 a más de una semana de la
inversión rusa ucrania al mundo de la
cultura está en alerta el conflicto
afecta principalmente a los soldados y a
la población pero los bombardeos también
suponen un peligro para el patrimonio y
los museos una institución ya ha sido
destruida por rusia el museo y banquina
cerca de la capital quemando unos 25
cuadros de la célebre artista ucraniana
mariya primas en goes según informó el
lunes el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores del país por miedo a sufrir
el mismo destino los museos entraron en
una lucha contrarreloj para salvar sus
colecciones sacar las obras del país o
colocarlas en sótanos y prepararse para
un ataque como lo hicieron los empleados
del museo de etnografía arte y artesanía
de elvis colocando cubiertas metálicas
en las ventanas para esperar protegerlas
de las ondas de choque de los bombardeos
por parte de los artistas cuyos trabajos
y vidas quedan en suspenso se plante la
cuestión a huir o quedarse france24
hablo con uno que hizo su elección se
llama pablo maco y estaba preparando su
instalación para la bienal de arte
contemporáneo de venecia cuando la
invasión rusa llegó a su puerta en
hardcore la segunda ciudad del país el
artista gráfico nos contó por teléfono
el miércoles justo cuando hardcore
estaba bajo ataque porque se niega a
abandonar su hogar
y llevo 30 años aquí desde la
independencia del país para promoverlo
para hablar de sus problemas y de su
vida siempre he representado a este país
por lo que me sería moralmente imposible
huir de casa destruiría toda mi vida
como artista y lo que soy
es la paralización que sufren los
artistas en ucrania se extiende más allá
de las fronteras pero esta vez de forma
deliberada y contra el arte ruso otras
medidas de protestas y de boicots como
las que tuvieron lugar en la bienal de
venecia que se celebrará a partir del 23
de abril
con el resto de la delegación de ucrania
nadie habían expresado su negativa a
participar si rusia estaba presente pero
la semana pasada los miembros del
pabellón ruso en la bienal renunciaron
ellos mismos en protesta contra la
guerra los artistas rusos alexandra su
carrera y kiril saben sin kof
escribieron en sus redes sociales que no
hay lugar para el arte cuando los
civiles están muriendo bajo el fuego de
los misiles cuando los ciudadanos
ucranianos se esconden en los refugios
cuando los manifestantes rusos son
silenciados de hecho se puede observar
un movimiento de artistas y actores de
la cultura rusos expresando su
desacuerdo con la guerra en ucrania
entre ellos la directora del teatro
estatal y centro cultural mayor de moscú
elena kowalska ya que dimitió la semana
pasada diciendo me resulta imposible
trabajar para un asesino y recibir un
salario de él otra acción notable fue la
del director musical de la ópera estatal
de baviera en alemania vladimir jurowski
que comió la apertura de su concierto
6 de febrero en la filarmónica de berlín
pasando de la marcha eslava de
tchaikovsky al himno ucraniano
reacciones que la franco rusa y
directora del teatro público en francia
luz y verlo bitch felicita esta autora
de una tribuna pidiendo que las artistas
ucranianos huidos sean acogidos en
francia pero en una entrevista con
france 24 sigue reclamando una mayor
movilización en el sector cultural ruso
yo misma tengo un origen familiar ruso
por lo que estoy en contacto muy
estrecho con los artistas del país con
el sector cultural y el sector
intelectual lo que se nota es que la
movilización podría haber sido más
importante pero hay protestas que
tuvieron lugar en san petersburgo y
moscú a pesar de estar prohibidas por
las autoridades pienso que es esencial
que la intelectualidad se manifieste
ayer leí una entrevista al director de
teatro life the dim que dijo que los
intelectuales rusos tienen que ser más
francos no pueden quedarse callados
antes
hablamos ahora de las reacciones de
parte del mundo cultural internacional
aunque gran parte de la atención se ha
centrado en las sanciones destinadas a
paralizar la economía rusa la influencia
cultural del país también se está
reduciendo a través de medidas como las
múltiples suspensiones del director de
orquesta ruso valery gergiev conocido
por ser cercano a vladimir putin tras la
scala de milán el carnegie hall de nueva
york canceló su aparición y la orquesta
filarmónica de munich de la que varios
georgieff era director musical rompió su
contrato el boicot a rusia se extendió a
todos los ámbitos culturales artistas
musicales desde iu y pop hasta franz
ferdinand cancelaron sus actuaciones en
el país y el concurso musical televisivo
eurovisión rechazó la participación de
rusia este año del lado del cine sony y
disney y warner bros cancelaron sus
estrenos en rusia mientras que la
dirección del festival de cannes decidió
no acoger delegaciones rusas en mayo
además de las reacciones y sanciones
la semana de guerra en ucrania también
mostró una ola de apoyo y de gestos de
solidaridad numerosas figuras famosas
como los cantantes madonna y lenny
kravitz o la pareja de actores blake
lively y ryan reynolds se movilizaron en
sus redes sociales y múltiples acciones
más anónimas surgieron también en todas
partes del mundo como este concierto
benéfico en praga el primero de marzo en
la muy simbólica plaza de wenceslao
miles de personas asistieron a
actuaciones para recaudar fondos para
ucrania
[Música]
nos despedimos con una nota positiva el
abrazo el domingo 27 de febrero de la
ucraniana liudmyla monastyrska en azul y
la rusa ekaterina gubanova naranja al
final de su representación de ayuda en
el teatro san carlo de nápoles en italia
nadie sabe cómo evolucionará la
situación en las próximas semanas pero
las seguiremos muy de cerca aquí en
france 24 gracias por su confianza y
cuídense
[Aplausos]